now we're all in need of a route map for
the next 36 days but on day three then
use is big business and the city gate
crashing this campaign with an entirely
predictable repeat of a conservative
tactic from five years ago which was a
high-profile letter from dozens of
business leaders supporting conservative
economic policy saying that it helps
create jobs and stability all that sort
of thing this issue this time was
particularly corporation tax which the
Labor Party say they'll raise by a penny
last time it was the so-called jobs tax
national insurance to take away the
interesting thing this time though is
the Labor Party doesn't mind doesn't
think that this type of tactic will
actually harm it it might even help it
is the thinking helped define ed
miliband if you like us standing up to
what he sees as vested interest in fact
labor went further they launch another
slightly business baiting policy which
was a clamp down on zero-hours contracts
that there you have it both parties the
main parties aren't fighting for the
same center ground they're playing to
their own galleries whether it's the
business vote on one side or people on
zero-hours contracts on the other that
was day three